[Music]
[Applause]
this is Justin Schmidt my name is Justin
Schmidt
he's an entomologist and I'm an
entomologist I basically study stinging
insects he's been stung by a lot of
insects I've probably been stung at
least a thousand times he reviews in
sexting the way a somali a reviews wine
pure intense brilliant pain like walking
or flaming charcoal as a three-inch nail
embedded in your heel which insect was
that
that's the bullet ants this is his lab
in Tucson this is it harvester and this
is his vinegaroon
this is a tarantula hawk these are some
more harvester ants in a park near lab
he is the creator of the Schmidt pain
camp the Schmidt pain scale is basically
a scaled erase of painfulness of
stinging insects on a scale of one to
four a one would be a sweat bee 2 would
be something like a yellow jacket one
the three would be something like a
harvester ant and a four would be a
tarantula hawk how bad is it for four
it's absolutely excruciatingly
debilitating in cheap-ass attending to
shut you down
just absolute sheer pain is just nothing
you can really do about that I don't
think I'd want to be stung by a whole
bunch of different forward I don't think
I could endure that for very long let's
be clear justice Schmidt doesn't just go
out and get stung on purpose
it's just that he's dedicated his life
to studying well my passion is insects
and stinging insects in particular yeah
I get stung with that that's all just
part of the passion you know that gives
me data you know sting helps me and
understanding what the insects doing it
I get to be out in the sunshine and out
in the rain out in the environment
magnificent beautiful insects just such
a joy I can't imagine anything I'd
rather do more
[Music]
it makes perfect sense for us to be
eating invasive species because invasive
species are an endless resource for food
my name is bond Lai and the chef that me
is sushi in New Haven 33 years ago my
mother started me as reimagining sushi
is something that is restorative of the
environment
this is part of the regimen that happens
every day in the morning foraging one of
the things that we're really focused on
is invasive species what if we start
focusing on ingredients that nobody else
wants to eat that are abundant and even
destructed with the environment and by
pulling them out of the environment will
help rebalance that habitat
this is wild lettuce and we're going to
serve them with Buggles and it's like
Swiss cheese that means that they're
they're healthy to eat and that their
pesticide herbicide free here is a big
one really can't hesitate have to be
fully committed protection see if I
manage gosh they're a lot stronger than
you think he's really pushing off my
hand yeah where's that to go it's rock
and roll
[Music]
great these snails from Europe they're
called European snail camp over stuck on
ships I feel like you're like a big kid
just crawling around looking under rocks
when I'm collecting it's always
incredibly exciting it's very thrilling
for me
well alright but when I'm trying to
figure out new ways of working with an
ingredient that I've never worked with
before or an ingredient that actually
grosses me out I like the fact that I'm
forcing myself to confront my own
prejudices today we went foraging for
dandelion amaranth wild lettuce mugwort
butterbur grasshopper invasive European
snails a whole bunch of Asian Shore crap
and what common seaweed and gretel eras
do weed are you gonna be mad if we show
the whole world that you can make
gourmet sushi just using stuff in your
backyard that's what we want the whole
world to do or consider doing or think
about doing and not only that this isn't
an original idea people have been doing
this for tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of years way before before me
is and it's a listen and it's absolutely
delicious and nutritious and great for
the environment
you
this is the red new tarantula
she's got quite the outfit unfortunately
her striking features have made her a
hot commodity in the illegal pet trade
found in the forests of southwestern
Mexico red needs are some of the larger
spiders growing up to eight inches in
size
besides size their beautiful red white
black and orange heads are what
separates them from other spiders the
hairs on their legs are used to sense
vibrations from predators and prey they
prey on large insects frogs and mice
biting and injecting them with their
venom their alluring look has made them
the most popular captive tarantula
causing a major population decline today
regulations are in place requiring
permits to remove any of these beauties
from the wild this is the red knee
tarantula
[Music]
it was a trial that captivated a nation
lorena bobbitt Lorena Bobbit Lorena
Bobbit took a knife cut off her husband
Pina but what does lorena bobbitt have
to do with this thing well the sickest
effect this is the bhavet worm it's a
species of Yunus Union you nicely thanks
Terry you're most welcome
that's dr. Terry gasps honor ter ry g
inna senior curator at the California
Academy of Sciences and I do research on
coral reefs around the world he's the
one who gave the body warm its name they
go way back in 1992 I went to the
Philippines and I saw my first Bobbitt
work to actually see it in action was
really one of the most amazing things
I've seen this thing has nope nope nope
written all over it
I'm sorry what from its spike glowing
exoskeleton and the body is very
iridescent shiny - its spring-loaded
jaws they just spring shut like a bear
trap and it's unique predatory style
when it sees a fish it pops more and
more out of the water and then grabs the
fish and picks it back into the sand
what anyway after years of research in
the indo-pacific dr. josh turner
published this book coral reef animals
of the indo-pacific when it came time to
name the worm
dr. Gosselaar found an unlikely source
of inspiration there was this guy named
John Wayne Bobbitt who had cheated on
his wife and while he was sleeping one
night she cut off his penis and threw it
in a field nearby wait what and in the
worm basically the ability to use as
massive jaws to cut the spinal cord of a
fish was something that reminded me of
what Lorena Bobbitt did to her husband
there you have it
something else keep you up at night
I've never had nightmares about it
whatever dr. Terry
[Music]